de la soirée on va regarder la
prestation qui a fait le plus parl c'est
la chenille synchronisée de Vincent qui
sera avec nous juste après ça fait du
bien je te le
dis bonsoir comment vous appelez-vous je
m'appelle lapig ch pardon alors en fait
voilà je suis prof de
[Applaudissements]
chenille cadence gauche standard départ
l lâ
[Applaudissements]
l
mer merci merci d'être avec nous
franchement comment ça
va je vous sens perturbé pas du tout
vent ça va bien Vincent oui super
j'adore votre tenue alors vous êtes prof
et je connais aucune ex à vous deux je
vous le dis tout de suite on arrête avec
ça cal Cal et n'écoute pas tout ce qu'il
dit c'est un ramass est-ce que tu peux
le dire parce que là tout le monde m'éc
ou oui arrêtons avec ça ah voilà non
mais tu Jean-Michel fautêre j'espère que
tu diras la vérité avant la fin de
l'émission par que ça met ça met mal
tout le monde ça va va alors tu es
vraiment prof de chenis oui je suis prof
de chenille là depuis un an et demi
enfin je suis comédien et auteur parce
que frère comment on devient prof de
chenille c'est une passion en fait je
fais la chenille synchronisée he c'est
pas de la de la que leuse non c'est
comme la natation synchronisée mais en
chenille ouais c'est pas mal donc c'est
sans danger on a pied
donc et non voilà j'ai toujours aimé
faire de la Chun c'était mon premier
sketch j'étais humoriste ça a été la le
chuniste mais je me rappelle de toi
ouais et après oui mais j'ai même
travaillé avec vous moi j'ai ouais j'ai
travaillé avec vous j'éta j'étais pas
très bon je tapais avec un doigt j'étais
hauteur et tout et mon truc c'est la
danse voilà toi tu as trouvé ton truc
quoi j'ai trouvé mon truc donc voilà je
suis toujours comédien et moi j'ai un
coup de cœur pour toi merci vraiment non
mais je suis comédien j'ai aussi une
pièce de TH joue avec patri chanfr vous
conna donc voilà on a on a joué 5 ans
une pièce qui était produite par Artus
et là maintenant j'ai une corde à mon
arc de plus c'est que je suis chorégrap
ou de
chenill bravo je vois que la tenue est
très forte merci B c'est j'ai monté la
la premire école de chenis de France
c'est la chenis School academmie vous en
aviez parlé une fois c'est vrai et voilà
et maintenant ben voilà la France uncop
talent a voulu que je participe et
effectivement bah la France entière a vu
ce que c'était que la chenille
synchronisée quoi et comment il se
déroule le cours un cours de chenille
c'est quoi exactement et ben en fait un
échauffement parce que ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir le poignet
souple et la main ferme ok donc on peut
le faire d'ailleurs souple souple ferme
soupp souple fer nésitez pas le public
soupe soupe fer très bien voilà ok ça
évite de briser une chenille bien sûr et
sinon ensuite effectivement on fait des
on fait des moi c'est pas les chenilles
que je brise c'est les
couples non et puis je donne des noms de
passe et puis voilà comme voilà c'est
c'est chorégraphié synchronisé c'est
très beau mais moi j'adore franchement
vous avvez pas ce genre de
personn s il a une énergie incroyable ah
maisi je kiffe vraiment vous êtes
rayonnant ça fait plir atts hier il a
mis le feu au plateau c'était
génialett es
célibataire je me remets avec ma femme
moi non on a été séparé pendant 10 ans
je la connais
pas M de mes enfants apr c'est be Heou
elle a envie de revoir ta Chen bah c'est
ça mais c'est c'est mon papillon c'est
mon papillon très tu CIS par 10 ans avec
ta femme et tu te rems avec exactement
c'est magnifique
ça tu pouris pas le faire ça si par 10
ans avec un me donc je creuse
quoi et en tout cas reste avec nous là
reste avec
nous attends mais ouais tu V nous en
faire un là t'inquiète pas je voudrais
voir les deux trois trucs hier le Golden
buzzer n'emmène plus en finale mais en
demi-finale ça c'est important le C
parce qu'il y a plein de gens qui m'ont
écrit pour aller en final il faut
maintenant un Platinum
buzz que les qu durés valid g Verdez il
est beaucoup plus tu parles plus sur la
c'est un incroyable talent quand on
parle de ta meuf mais la vraie nouveauté
c'est juju fitcat qui anime l'after elle
était pas mal he j' bien aimé très forte
regardez bravo Ju si l'on place les
candidats internationaux d'incroyaable
talent sur l'échelle de la baritude la
bizarie quoi disons qu'on aurait les
originaux les décalés les déjantés les
complètement jetés la juju juu la juju
la juju la juju juju ok la juju
juju ce qui se passe actuellement sur
scène c'est pour moi la définition même
de l'incroyable
talent on est sur un niveau mais ici
quoi comment est-ce que tu t'es rendu
compte que tu avais ce
[Musique]
talent
alors au niveau des prestations hier il
y en a eu 15 10 oui 5 non dont un oui
pour Vincent et sa choni bravo Vincent
bravo chéri je suis très heureux pour
toi et comme chaque saison on a une un
petit florilèage de prestation un petit
peu chelou notamment une meuf qui a
300000 ans du moins c'est son âge
elfique regardez une collègue à toi
[Rires]
dan je suis Olivia fait céleste fait de
la nature puisque je vis principalement
en
[Musique]
nature je vous en
suppli
ouais ça ça a pas été retenu he non elle
a expliqué et ça a cartonné hier soir et
ce qui fait du bien dans cette émission
c'est ce qu'il y a ce qu'on appelle un
peu les casseroles dans les ancienes
émissions c'est des candidats qui se
prennent pas au sérieux qui sont cool et
c'est la seule émission où il y a ça
maintenant c'est alors j'ai demandé au
chroniqueur je vous cache pas je vous
dis à 19h53 de préparer un numéro pour
un incroyable talent il y en a pas un
qui a trouve un truc hein vraiment on
voit pourquoi vous nêtes vous êtes là
tout le monde m' diti moi je sais
hypnotisé ah ouais bah vas-y attendez
parce que j'hypnotise pas n'importe qui
en fait fa que met dans les conditions
je vais hypnotiser Guillaume jenton vous
permettez vous allez surtout vous [__]
de ma
gueule c'était quoi vos talents au
autres ça me fait peur ça moi je tire
pas je tire pas beaucoup mais je vise
juste vraiment j'ai un truc de dingue
quoi oui oui je gagne tous les concours
que je veux sur pas tu fais des concours
de tir toi non mais j'en ai fait par
hasard et à chaque fois je je mets dans
dans le l'autre fois concours de
fléchette c'est moi qui ai gagné le sur
tes ah non mais un truc de dingue ouais
çaon incroyable
est la tristesse c'est quoi toi j'en ai
pas de talent ça j'avis tuas pas un
incroyable talent bon jacqu on c'est un
danseur il en a rmon il en a un pourquoi
vous lu demandz
pas bah attends tu nous as dit tout à
l'heure il est pas à
l'aise tu es capable de deviner le le
poids c'est moi c'est
guum c'est quo l'oire je suis capable de
deviner le poids exact des gens sans les
connare ah ouais très très fort ah ouais
bah vas-y bah qui par exemple moi Jean-M
non Jean-M non je pasfèire les femmes
Jeanmi tu peux faire Delphine 89 il fait
89 non c'est ça fait plus que 89 c'est
bon c'est bon les mecs on va pas faire 2
heures là-dessus donc oui voilà Jacques
cardose il fait
865 à 100 g pr ça je peux très bien leur
demander avant l'émission du tout c'est
ce qu'il a fait vasy demande dis-moi moi
alors vous vous faites vas-y 79 pas du
tout combien plus 75
habillé 79 non non ah vous es très très
F 75 kg ouais je su 75 k si bah vous
pvez appelez-moi un truc vous dit je
fais 75 kg donner les vra fois moi des
mecsis
104 JAC 98 moi
92 arrête les conneries toi tu passes
quoi bonsoir moi c'est une station radio
connue autoroute FM quoi 107
107 fait quoi 1077 ouaisouais il faut
que je euh on va parler d'une autre
prestation trois prestas chelous qui ont
fait pas mal parler sur les réseaux
c'est un gars en slip un gars qui fait
des chansons en faisant des proutes avec
les mains et un mec qui bouge comme sil
s'était fait tasé regardez ah
[Musique]
oui on dirait qu'il a une crise
épilepsie mais c'est pas mal mais en
fait il est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
juste alors r tu fais incroyable
tal tranquille tu Pr direct tuapp même
pas la quoi c'est normal
ça franchement je suis pas content
frérot je suis pas content non non non
mais moi j'ai bien aimé ça j'aime bien
moi j'aime bien tout ce qui est festif
franchement comme toi j'adore c'est vrai
cette émission elle a fait du bien
d'ailleurs ça a bien marché fait à
beaucoup de monde 3,8 million de
téléspectateurs hier c'est France 3 qui
était en tête d'ailleurs des audiences
hier soir on a aussi un gars qui s'est
très très bien démerdé sur des
imitations de chanteurs c'est pas mal ça
regarde
fort je suis une
cruche percé de plus il est trop fort
j'ai la peau
craquelée je crois qu'elle est toute
séchée veu accepter mesdames ces
quelques mots comme un hommage dans
votre j que j'admire qui fr chaque homme
un orage au cinéma dans la vie vous êtes
le plus beau personnage et sans le
vouloir vous tenz no cœur et autre chose
en nototage toujours vivant
rassurez-vous toujours la banane
toujours de pour
je suis retapé remis pour moi c'est très
simple c'est un grand oui
bravo c'est pas mal pas mal que vous
imitez super bien
johnnyidy non mais j'ai donné des
conditions elles sont pas réunies les
conditions condition j'avais dit costume
promp demain demain vous inquitez pas
demain t'qui pas on est là t les SOS pas
on est là tous les soir demain je vais
vous peser vous
allez lui ça vare ça êre un beau bordel
de et forcément tous les ans il y a des
histoires touchantes un couple qui a
fait sa demande en mariage sur la scène
et un duo qui dansait sur le thème de la
violence conjugale qui a eu un
golden mérité m franchement et la
demande en mariage était très réussie
bah plus que la
tienne beaucoup plus que la tienne
voilà si tu CS un jour je te laisserai F
la fin de l'été ma cas pas passer n' pas
peur personne d'autre
[Applaudissements]
pourit je revois le début les premières
semaines on pourrait repartir à zéro et
prendre le premier avion comme dans un
film de merde notre histoire n'aurait
jamais pu finir dans le calme et la
tendresse
[Musique]
ouais e ouais c'est pas mal oui le
Golden buzzer était mérité parce que sur
le thème de la violence conjugale ils
ont transfiguré ça dans une danse qui
était extraordinaire franchement il
dénonçaient ça il le si je puis dire il
le jouaiit en même temps c'était
magnifique franchement parfois on dit
ils sont sélectionnés que parce qu'ils
défendent une cause S av l'art et la
cause franchement magnifique ouais moi
aussi hein ah oui la cause de cause
aussi les chéris juste reste avec nous
parce qu'on parle de j'ai l'opportunité
de la journée pour vous qui nous